radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene now
has come up with the wild claim
that antifa killed a police officer this
is not true this took place during a
recent hearing lgbtq Nation says
Marjorie Taylor green told Congress
antifa killed a cop she was dead wrong
police shot Manuel Teran 57 times green
said their proof that leftists kill cops
let's go to the hearing where Marjorie
Taylor green is now wearing glasses
apparently an attempt to look more
intelligent I don't know you want to
talk about human lives well is
sir
Target
murdered someone there they actually
murdered a place oh you don't know
that's right because you don't study
left-wing extremism from your
non-partisan uh so-called non-profit but
let me tell you about it there was a a
26 year old activist manual uh Tehran
shot and killed Georgia State Patrol
Trooper there that was this year you're
right not last year it was this year so
left-wing extremism is definitely on the
rise and murder is a big part of it okay
that is false and misleading the
individual she's referring to and it's
not manual like your VCR manual it's
Manuel Manuel Teran was not a member of
antifa
he was an environmental activist who
opposed the con construction of a police
training facility in Atlanta
he was killed by police officers who
shot 57 times during a raid on the
protest Camp no police officer was
killed in the incident it just it's not
what it's not even a question of who did
The Killing no police officer was killed
in the incident there was a state
trooper injured by a gunshot it might
have come from a fellow officer and it
might have come from the officer's own
firearm
okay that's a very different story to
what Marjorie Taylor green told there so
is she a liar of course
is she dishonest yeah is she ignorant
absolutely does she have no business in
a position of legislative power in the
United States a hundred and ten percent
but it's also important to understand
the dangerous nature of how they Inspire
violence this is a form of stochastic
terrorism where if you lie enough
about the supposed acts of violence that
are being committed by your political
opponents when they are not committing
such acts of violence
you in a way
Inspire
legitimize or approve of signal approval
for your side continuing to to commit
the act of violence that they are
actually committing remember the
overwhelming political violence in the
United States is right wing and then I
mean listen we've talked about this
before the the numbers no matter how you
slice and dice them are very clear
and so this is not only all based on
lies I would argue it is a form of
stochastic terrorism by Marjorie Taylor
green we will see whether these sorts of
folks get another uh swing at the ball I
don't know what you want to call it but
uh in 2024
we may see these sorts of folks made a
more permanent part of American politics
or it may be the end of Maga My Hope Is
that 2024 is the end of Maga I don't
know that I will be correct a Monday
Memorial Day we will have our one day
membership special I would really love
for you to become a member on Memorial
Day you know we've been doing the show
for a long time and as I've said before
we estimate that somewhere between 0.7
and 0.9 percent of our audience supports
us financially that's fine we do the
show quite literally for the 99.3
percent that don't contribute and we're
glad to do it
it also is true if we were able to get a
full one percent of our audience
supporting our work or even one and a
half percent it's a game changer the
things we would be able to do so I would
love for you to join the ranks of
membership yes you do get the daily
bonus show when you become a member oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money true everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad as you
can see Alex Jones hates the bonus show
but on Monday Memorial day we'll be
blowing out memberships at prices I
can't even mention out loud because it
would just make my face red so get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and then
Monday Memorial day you'll get an email
it'll tell you what to do and we will do
the thing
if you've been getting crushed in the
markets lately like many people have you
were probably happy to hear that
treasury yields have been surging right
now you can get a five percent yield on
treasury bills Which is higher than most
high-yield savings accounts I've seen
and unlike a high-yield savings account
treasury bills are a fixed rate asset so
you know what you're getting at the time
of purchase but buying U.S treasuries
can be very complicated or at least it
was because our sponsorpublic.com lets
you buy treasury bills in seconds right
from your phone and put your cash to
work keep in mind that treasury bills
are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
around when you buy them on public they
are securely stored at the Bank of New
York Mellon the world's largest
custodian bank and Security Services
Company plus there are no minimum hold
periods or settlement delays you can
access funds anytime if you keep it
invested public will automatically roll
over your Investments at maturity so you
have one thing you don't have to think
about go to public.com Pacman to start
getting that five percent yield on your
cash the link is down below